delivering millions of covert 19
vaccines
involves distribution centers
refrigerated trucks
and cold storage facilities and each of
these could be a target for hackers
covent has been just a golden
opportunity for cyber criminals
and they've taken full advantage of it
since the start of the pandemic there
have been attempts to scam
individuals and businesses for money as
well as steal vaccine research
or hold data ransom for a payment and a
week before the first vaccinations in
the world began in the uk
interpol warned that criminal
organizations were planning to
infiltrate and disrupt the vaccine
supply chain
hackers are looking for a way to tamper
with the distribution
the cold chain network that enables the
delivery of temperature sensitive
covid19 vaccines
like the one developed by pfizer and
biontech that has to be kept at minus 70
degrees celsius
the payoffs are really big the people
that are doing it
are increasingly sophisticated so how
are hackers targeting the vaccine
rollout and is there a way to stop them
hackers have been honing their skills
for years by going after hospitals
the average hospital doesn't have very
good cyber security
criminals are eager to take advantage
of the concern that the
virus has raised jim lewis leads a cyber
security team at a washington-based
think tank
he says the easiest tool for hackers is
phishing
you send an email out to a hundred
people
the odds are very good that two of them
will click on it
what the covid vaccine creates is the
opportunity to do this
on a massive scale and that means you
can ask for a massive ransom
if someone clicks on a malicious link or
opens an attachment
the person may be prompted to download
malware or
enter login details giving the attacker
access to the network
and its data during the pandemic fishers
set up bait with emails sent to
hospitals about covid19 prevention
and setting up pandemic funds and now
that the vaccines are on their way
hackers are taking on new identities to
infiltrate cold chain companies
like ones that manufacture solar panels
to power refrigerators
or it firms that support biotech and
pharmaceutical clients
the i think the messages were very
special specifically crafted to to
to get people at these companies to to
respond
uh but in general this whole problem of
coronavirus being a lure for scammers
is huge ibm recently tracked down a
phishing campaign that targeted a
variety of these companies
the hacker was disguised as a project
manager from the chinese company hire
biomedical
which his website says is the world's
only complete cold chain provider
the writer said it would send an advance
payment of around 220
000 the message went on to ask that the
reader review the attached draft
contract
which is actually a malicious attachment
ibm says it's unclear if any victims
clicked on the file and fell for this
scam
and doesn't know which nation state
might be behind it
if there were any victims ibm says the
harvested credentials could give the
hacker insight into internal
communications
as well as methods and plans to
distribute the kovid19 vaccine
higher biomedical says it condemns the
perpetrators of the phishing email
and is working with international
organizations to ensure that these
incidents
don't deter the fight against the
pandemic but if hackers do successfully
access a system
they can encrypt the data making it
unreadable
this can happen to logistics companies
responsible for delivering the vaccine
and so you can imagine locking up this
picture and locking up
distribution codes or locking the trucks
and saying unless you pay you won't be
able to deliver
but some systems in the cold chain would
be harder to hack
the actual operation of a refrigerator
that would be
specialized uh operating system and that
would be
uh configured in a way that was unusual
so they'd have to figure out how they
work
so what's more likely to happen is that
hackers will go after low-hanging fruit
they're already making tons of money
just hitting standard
windows operating machines so if if you
were working for
a refrigeration company i'd be worried
about the
sort of the back office equipment that
the the sales people use
the the the you know the laptops and the
desktops
and maybe some of the servers after all
according to a survey by a healthcare it
consultant
80 of health professionals say their
hospitals still use
legacy systems such as windows 2008
you need to do basic cyber hygiene which
includes training
two-factor authentication making sure
your patches and updates are installed
but on top of that you need to back up
your data and think about how you're
going to use cloud services
but given the high stakes of getting
more people vaccinated
no amount of drills may prepare the cold
chain for the months to come
this has changed from uh efforts to
steal the formula
efforts to blackmail people about
distribution
so we're seeing the cyber crime evolve
when it comes to covet